Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Ceux et celles qui écoutaient déjà Septante Minutes Avec le lendemain se souviennent peut-être que y a longtemps, pendant toute la première saison, je publiais sans faute un épisode toutes les deux semaines et que ça ne s'arrêtait jamais.
Pas mal de choses ont changé dans ma vie depuis et y a aussi eu une petite pandémie qui est passée par là entre-temps.
Forcément, ça ne facilite pas les choses, mais je voulais tout de même m'excuser sincèrement parce que dans les faits, on est plutôt passé à une diffusion d'un épisode par mois, ce qui me désole totalement.
Je fais de mon mieux pour trouver des invités, pour rechercher des sujets, mais voilà,
c'est pas toujours facile. Vous savez que dans ce podcast, j'aime beaucoup prendre une problématique, de préférence un sujet autour duquel il y a beaucoup d'idées reçues et inviter un ou une experte pour mettre les choses au clair.
Et c'est pas toujours simple, il faut du flair. C'est très facile de tomber sur des soi-disant experts qui sont en fait surtout des beaux parleurs qui adorent être sous le feu des projecteurs.
Et du coup, pour ce 37e épisode, j'étais hyper content de tomber sur Chloé Tolmatcheff.
Chloé est chercheuse en sciences de l'éducation et elle se spécialise sur la question du harcèlement scolaire,
sujet dont on va parler aujourd'hui et autour duquel il y a évidemment plein d'idées reçues et de soi-disant experts qui viennent faire leurs intéressants sur les plateaux télé.
Chloé est quelqu'un qui déborde de passion pour ce sujet et qui accorde justement beaucoup d'importance à dénoncer ce genre de discours fallacieux et à le faire avec soin dans le respect de la démarche scientifique.
On s'est donc posés ensemble pendant 70 minutes pour parler de ce qui cause le harcèlement scolaire,
de ce qui se passe dans la tête des harceleurs, dans la tête des enfants qui sont pris pour cible et des programmes mis en place dans les écoles pour lutter contre ce harcèlement.
Je suis vraiment très content de l'avoir trouvée et de pouvoir lui permettre de parler de son travail. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Chloé Tolmatcheff. Salut Chloé.
Salut Guillaume.
Alors Chloé, tu es chercheuse à l'Institut de recherche en sciences psychologiques à l'UCLouvain, au sein du GIRSEF. Tu es doctorante aspirante FNRS et tu te spécialises sur la question du harcèlement scolaire.
Est-ce que c'est juste ? Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Non, ça m'a l'air très complet.
Parfait. Mais du coup, qu'est-ce qui t'a amenée à travailler sur le harcèlement scolaire spécifiquement ?
Alors en fait, ça date de mes études, donc au moment du choix du thème de mémoire. Donc faut imaginer, j'étais en psycho à l'ULB, étudiante et, à cette époque-là, je réalise mes stages de fin d'études
en unité de crise adolescent à l'hôpital.
Et je m'intéresse particulièrement au processus de résilience. Donc toutes ces trajectoires de vie de personnes qui,
qui rencontrent en fait des événements traumatiques ou, ben, dans le cas du harcèlement, on va dire plutôt qui sont soumis à de l'adversité vraiment chronique
et qui réussissent à surmonter quelque part cette adversité, à se construire et à, voilà, à se construire en tant que personne.
OK.
Probablement que j'étais un peu toujours intriguée par aussi l'histoire, on va dire, de ma famille.
Donc je suis issue, on va dire, d'une famille d'immigrés avec des histoires qu'on me racontait qui étaient vraiment incroyables.
Enfin, je veux dire, des trajectoires de vie et des vécus tout à fait, on pourrait effectivement en écrire des romans.
C'était aussi des vécus très très durs. Je pense que c'était—
alors, je ne sais pas si c'était une époque plus dure qu'aujourd'hui, je ne suis pas sûre, mais en tout cas, voilà, une époque en tout cas où on pouvait, ben, perdre un enfant, perdre, enfin,
vivre des choses vraiment qui font froid dans le dos.
Et quelque part, j'étais très impressionnée, petite, d'entendre ces récits et puis de regarder mes parents et de me dire : « Tiens, mais enfin, comment quelque part est-ce qu'ils ont réchappé à, eh bien, à tant de souffrance ?
» en fait. Je peux le dire comme ça. Donc la résilience, ça m'intéressait. C'est quelque chose que j'avais l'impression qu'on se transmettait dans la famille.
OK. C'est très freudien tout ça.
Si tu le dis.
J'adore faire des blagues sur Freud avec les psychologues. Mais donc, OK, oui. Donc, ce passif familial a un peu formé, en tout cas en partie, formé ton intérêt pour la question de la résilience.
Ouais.
Et donc te voilà à travailler sur la question du harcèlement scolaire.
Oui, ça, c'était plus probablement parce qu'à ce moment-là, étant en stage avec les adolescents, etc. Et du coup, ben voilà, y avait des,
des jeunes femmes anorexiques, y avait d'autres qui étaient là, ben justement pour ce qu'on appellerait maintenant harcèlement scolaire.
Et donc l'un dans l'autre, y a eu ce sujet de mémoire qui était proposé. Je l'ai pris, et ça m'a amenée à rencontrer du coup d'anciennes victimes en fait, de harcèlement.
Alors à l'époque, on parlait pas de harcèlement comme on en parle aujourd'hui. C'était pas aussi répandu, ce mot.
Et donc j'ai appelé ça les phénomènes de bouc émissaire.
OK.
Donc mon mémoire, c'est la résilience dans les phénomènes de bouc émissaire à l'école primaire.
C'est si récent que ça le terme harcèlement scolaire ?
Oui, ça fait cinq, six ans, quelque chose comme ça. Alors, je dis pas que ça n'existait pas, mais c'était en tout cas pas le terme par défaut qui était utilisé en francophonie.
OK. Et côté anglo-saxon, il me semble que le mot bullying est beaucoup plus vieux.
Tout à fait.
Et côté néerlandophone, pesten, ouais. C'est aussi quelque chose qui est plus, enfin qui est pas si récent que ça ?
Ben je dirais que dans le cas, en tout cas dans le monde anglophone, bullying, c'est vraiment un mot qui a toujours fait partie, on va dire, du jargon, enfin
des mots que les enfants emploient spontanément à l'école s'ils se font effectivement embêter de façon—
C'est plus intuitif que harcèlement.
C'est plus in— oui, c'est ça. Harcèlement, aujourd'hui, ça paraît normal à tout le monde, mais il faut bien se dire qu'à l'époque, c'était plus un mot qui venait du monde du travail, hein.
On parlait de harcèlement professionnel, harcèlement au travail. Et donc c'est, voilà, peut-être un petit peu moins naturel comme terme, mais maintenant, clairement, il est là et il a l'avantage de permettre qu'on en parle.
Et ça, rien que pour ça, je ne vais pas critiquer du coup le choix du mot.
Mais du coup, comment est-ce que tu travailles exactement ? Tu vas sur le terrain ? Tu fais des recherches en bibliothèque ?
Tu vas à des conférences ? Quel genre de chercheuse es-tu ?
Alors oui, je disais que j'étais étudiante en psycho, etc. J'ai clairement changé de cap puisque maintenant, je suis chercheuse, plus en psychologie pure, mais en sciences de l'éducation.
C'est lié, évidemment. Et en plus, j'ai changé d'université aussi. Maintenant, je suis à l'UCL, donc j'ai tout changé.
Il est possible de passer de l'ULB à l'UCLouvain. Y a pas de—
Ah sans aucun problème.
Y a plus de guerre d'université, c'est—
En tout cas pas dans ce sens-là. J'ai pas testé dans l'autre sens.
Et donc oui, je— désolé, je t'ai interrompue. Tu disais, enfin je te demandais quel genre de chercheuse tu es, comment est-ce que tu travailles ?
J'ai clairement un sujet qui est très, très lié au terrain. Donc je suis pas dans mon bureau toute la journée.
En fait, je teste expérimentalement des pistes de prévention du harcèlement. Ce qui veut dire que clairement, je recrute sur le terrain des écoles qui sont prêtes à participer à l'expérience, à collaborer là-dessus.
Et je forme des enseignants à mettre en place dans leur classe des interventions très précises, pour, auprès de leurs élèves, hein, donc.
Et moi, je mesure avant, je mesure après et j'explore un petit peu, voilà, l'efficacité de chaque piste précise.
Donc on aura l'occasion de reparler de ce que tu as pu constater sur le terrain, les différentes méthodes employées, les, voilà, parler méthodo.
Tu disais que tu cherchais des écoles qui étaient prêtes à expérimenter à ce niveau-là.
Mmm-hmm.
Est-ce qu'il y a des profils d'écoles qui sont plus réceptives à ce genre d'idées et d'autres moins ? Est-ce que—
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une école va accepter ou refuser ta proposition ?
Ben à l'heure actuelle, c'est assez facile. Je te dirais que y a six ans, quand on parlait de harcèlement, les écoles disaient : « Y a pas ça chez nous ».
À l'heure actuelle, elles ont plutôt un discours qui est : « Venez nous aider, on s'en sort pas avec ça ».
D'accord.
Ce qui est vrai. Elles sont vraiment fort démunies, peu outillées pour faire face à cette problématique. Et elles reçoivent toutes sortes d'injonctions.
En tout cas, y a une attente terrible, que ce soit de la part du politique ou des parents, qu'elles prennent ça en charge.
Mais finalement, on ne leur donne pas forcément les moyens ou les formations pour être en mesure de le faire. Donc la demande est là.
Et elle est là, elle est distribuée de manière équivalente partout. Y a pas certaines écoles très conservatrices qui font encore semblant que le harcèlement est absent.
Si, y en a, y en a quelques-unes, mais je dirais que c'est un discours qui est tellement difficile à tenir encore actuellement—
D'accord.
...et de plus en plus difficile. Et donc ça, ça s'entend de moins en moins.
En fait, ça me surprend que tu me dises que ça a changé. Qu'est-ce qui a changé ?
Je pense que c'est la médiatisation. Je pense que—
OK.
...depuis qu'on en parle, que tout le monde, voilà, voit les témoignages, entend les récits, etc.
En fait, c'est— on a juste ôté le couvercle et regardé un petit peu ce qu'il y avait en dessous.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que le couvercle a été ôté ?
Alors, je ne sais pas pourquoi à ce moment-là, d'autant qu'on est particulièrement en retard par rapport à l'international.
Les pays nordiques, pour pas les citer, ça fait 40 ans que—
Tout droit.
...ils sont conscients du problème, qu'ils ont développé des programmes, qu'ils les testent de façon vraiment rigoureuse, etc.
Et qu'ils ont une idée très précise de ce qui se passe chez eux. Alors peut-être que ça a fait tache d'huile ensuite.
Maintenant, chez nous, c'est arrivé vraiment sur le tard quoi.
Donc une vraie, une authentique inquiétude, une vraie préoccupation pour la question du harcèlement scolaire, à peu près partout.
Et donc c'est plutôt eux qui viennent te chercher.
Y a les deux. C'est-à-dire que y a beaucoup d'écoles qui souhaitent, par exemple, des séances d'information ou de sensibilisation ou alors une conférence pour les parents, des choses comme ça.
Or, c'est le genre de choses que je fais aussi. Et donc du coup, ça peut arriver que ça soit par ce biais-là. Mais,
pour en tout cas la plus grosse étude que j'ai menée ces deux dernières années, j'ai tout simplement diffusé l'information dans les réseaux que j'ai sur le terrain.
Et au total, je dirais que j'ai été en contact avec peut-être 25 écoles. Et au final, ça s'est concrétisé pour une dizaine avec lesquelles on a vraiment mené le projet du début à la fin quoi.
OK. Du coup, est-ce qu'il y a une idée reçue que tu aimerais corriger au sujet du harcèlement scolaire ? Quelque chose que—
Ouf, une seule ?
On va avoir l'occasion de développer, mais ouais, un truc qui ressort systématiquement et qui...
Alors peut-être un vieux mythe.
Oui.
De nouveau qu'on entend de moins en moins, hein, soyons clairs, voilà, c'est— mais qui a quand même, je trouve, la—
Qui reste bien ancré.
Qui reste, ouais, qu'on entend quand même encore ou alors qu'on n'ose plus dire, mais qu'on pense encore, avec cette idée de— Le harcèlement, ça forge le caractère.
Et ça, voilà, s'il y a—
On l'entend encore ouais.
...une seule idée que je devais complètement démonter, c'est celle-là. C'est dire non, non, trois fois non.
Jamais un enfant, un adolescent qui a été victime de harcèlement n'en sort plus fort. C'est toujours quelque chose qui est terriblement violent à vivre.
Alors bien sûr que on peut surmonter et c'est pas pour rien que je m'intéresse au processus de résilience. Donc je suis pas en train de dire qu'on,
que ça a toujours des conséquences catastrophiques, mais en aucun cas c'est quelque chose qu'on peut juger bénéfique ou anodin.
Ça non, certainement pas.
C'est effectivement quelque chose que j'ai pu entendre en faisant des recherches sur, ben surtout en France, ce témoignage, même au sein du staff des écoles
où on s'intéressait pas spécialement à la question parce que, vous savez, ça forge le caractère.
Mmm-hmm.
Ouais donc c'est, ça reste assez ancré. Et du coup, justement, le harcèlement scolaire, est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on observe partout, systématiquement, depuis toujours ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose de presque inévitable ou bien est-ce que c'est quelque chose de plutôt construit, plutôt culturel ?
Parce que, où est-ce que tu mets le curseur à ce niveau-là ?
Alors, non, moi, je dirais que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui existe depuis la nuit des temps. Donc, si on parle de harcèlement scolaire, ben je dirais que ça existe depuis la naissance de la scolarité—
Mmm.
...obligatoire, mais bien avant ça, si on regarde juste simplement, si on se retourne sur notre histoire, elle est ponctuée d'épisodes de boucs émissaires, pour— voilà, il suffit de faire référence ben au,
à, pas si, y a pas si longtemps que ça finalement, l'Holocauste, plus récemment, les génocides ethniques qui ont eu lieu au Rwanda,
même au Moyen Âge, la chasse aux sorcières—
Oui.
...finalement, c'était ça aussi. Ce que je veux dire, c'est que l'être humain—
...est assez bien maître dans l'art de se trouver des victimes—
Mmm.
...la plupart du temps innocentes, qu'il sacrifie, on va dire, au profit de la collectivité.
Oui, donc là, tu parles vraiment d'une envie systématique de hiérarchiser, de—
Je dis que dans—
...mettre un ordre d'importance et de s'autoriser à persécuter ceux qui sont en dessous.
Je dis que dans tout groupe humain—
Oui.
...c'est une dynamique qui peut apparaître. Alors, je dis pas qu'elle est inéluctable.
Mmm.
Y a toutes sortes de facteurs qui peuvent faire qu'un groupe fonctionne de façon saine sans avoir besoin de recourir à ça.
Mais ça existe depuis la nuit des temps. Y a un auteur, René Girard, qui parle de ça en 1982. Donc c'est pas—
C'est pas la nuit des temps.
Non, c'est pas la nuit des temps, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que c'est pas apparu il y a six ans quand on a commencé—
C'est ça.
...à parler de harcèlement quoi.
Oui, non, c'est sûr.
Et le terme même bouc émissaire, il est intéressant pour ça, parce qu'il fait référence à une tradition dans la re— dans, en judaïque—
Mmm
...où on sacrifie un bouc, donc on le charge du poids des péchés de toute la communauté et on l'envoie dans le désert se faire manger par le démon.
Une fois que c'est fait, l'équilibre est rétabli, la communauté est apaisée, à travers en fait vraiment le partage d'un exutoire commun, un dérivatif partagé qui renoue finalement la collectivité.
Alors, y a une espèce d'omerta, et t'es bien placée pour le savoir, au sujet du harcèlement en général et y compris le harcèlement scolaire.
C'est pas forcément facile de juger, de jauger à quel point les personnes qui nous entourent ont pu être ou sont encore concernées.
Donc c'est, voilà, une complication avec ce sujet. J'aurais intuitivement tendance à penser que le harcèlement scolaire est nettement plus important en termes de,
en termes de nombre, en termes de récurrence que, par exemple, de manière générale, le harcèlement dans le monde du travail.
Est-ce que c'est juste de penser ça ?
Ben je pense qu'on a quand même à l'heure actuelle pas mal d'informations, pas mal de chiffres sur le harcèlement scolaire.
Oui, c'est ça.
Je soupçonne qu'on en a moins du côté-
Voilà
...du harcèlement au travail.
OK.
Parce que finalement, c'est une question de santé publique et c'est aussi une obligation de la part de l'institution scolaire de garantir la sécurité-
Mmm
...le bien-être des élèves qu'elle accueille. Donc du coup, y a une légitimité à investiguer, à mesurer le harcèlement dans les écoles pour savoir ce qu'il en est.
Ouais. Mais donc si je pars du principe, j'espère ne pas me tromper, qu'il y a tout de même moins de harcèlement dans le monde des adultes, dans le monde du travail que-
Honnêtement, je suis pas sûre.
T'es pas sûre ? OK.
Mais je l'espère parce que-
Ouais
...le harcèlement scolaire est vraiment très prévalent donc...
OK.
Une comparaison que j'ai pu lire parfois, c'est une comparaison avec le,
le monde carcéral où en prison, là, on retrouve aussi ce harcèlement systématique, assumé, où on hiérarchise, où certains essayent de se placer au-dessus des autres.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette idée que y a un peu un-
Un parallèle à faire ?
En tout cas un mécanisme de compensation, de se dire : « Bon, je suis tout en bas de la pyramide, on ne m'accorde aucune valeur dans le système.
Alors j'espère-
J'ai envie de me valoriser un petit peu. Du coup, je vais essayer-
Mmm
...de monter en écrasant les autres, entre guillemets. Je vais me sentir important, me sentir cool, me sentir valorisé-
...en décidant que les autres sont en dessous de moi.
Alors y a certainement de ça. Je pense aussi, 'fin moi, je trouve le parallèle intéressant, même s'il est peut-être un petit peu trash-
Ouais
...mais avec la prison, parce que finalement, on parle de quoi ? Vingt à vingt-cinq gamins qui sont parqués ensemble dans une classe pour un an,
et qui le seront peut-être même avec la même classe pendant peut-être six ans, voire douze ans, et qui n'ont jamais demandé à être mis ensemble et à qui, effectivement, on ne donne pas le choix.
Alors, je pense que le parallèle avec une prison s'arrête là. Je veux pas pousser les choses trop loin, mais y a quand même cette idée que-
Ils n'ont pas choisi d'être ensemble et que ça contribue sans doute à favoriser l'émergence de ce genre de dynamique dans un groupe qui est forcé de fonctionner ensemble.
Alors après-
Dans le monde des adultes, on a tendance plutôt de se rapprocher des gens qu'on aime, qui nous ressemblent, qui nous plaisent.
Voilà, même si évidemment professionnellement, la marge de manœuvre peut être très limitée, mais y a tout l'à-côté où là, on est tout à fait libre de choisir les personnes qu'on fréquente, etc.
La scolarité obligatoire, c'est quand même 12 ans pendant lesquels on nous laisse absolument pas le choix par rapport à ça.
Et 12 ans, ça peut paraître très long quand justement, on n'est pas dans la position la plus agréable dans un groupe.
Alors après, tu parles un petit peu des motivations finalement de ceux qui harcèlent. Et là, ben, voilà, l'idée, c'est que y a une diversité de profils hein, chez les harceleurs.
Donc y a clairement pas une espèce de profil type avec des enfants qui seraient tous les mêmes, qui auraient tous les mêmes motivations.
Donc y a une diversité et je dirais que si on devait simplifier très très fort, on pourrait dire qu'y a deux grands types de profils.
Un profil d'enfant ou d'élève qui manque plutôt de compétences sociales, de compétences émotionnelles, etc.
Et qui utilise l'agression des autres comme moyen de domination, mais qui-
L'agression sur les autres, ouais
Ouais, l'agression sur les autres, mais qui n'est pas apprécié, 'fin qui n'est pas, c'est pas forcément valorisé par le reste du groupe.
Donc je dirais que les autres en ont peur ou sont impressionnés, mais dans son cas, c'est plutôt par manque de compétences sociales.
Un peu, on va dire, le stéréotype dans les films américains, de la grosse brute qui manque d'empathie, qui est pas forcément malin, etc.
Bon, c'est un peu cliché, mais ça résume peut-être un peu le profil. Un profil. Et de l'autre côté, on aurait justement des enfants qui sont très doués socialement.
Ils sont très doués, ils sont très malins. Et en fait, ces enfants, quelque part, tout simplement, ils trouvent un truc super facile qui marche super bien.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils se rendent compte qu'en s'en prenant à une personne qui est une cible bien choisie, on pourra en rediscuter aussi, eh bien, ils font rire les autres, ils se font remarquer, etc.
Et donc, ça les valorise aux yeux du groupe et ça leur amène une position effectivement dominante dans, tu parles de hiérarchie, ben voilà, dans la hiérarchie du groupe classe.
Mais donc, c'est pas nécessairement des enfants, comment dire ? On n'est pas forcément face à des enfants qui manquent d'empathie, qui sont incapables de se rendre compte de la souffrance qui crée chez l'autre, etc.
Mais on est face à des enfants malins, appréciés par les autres et qui trouvent une façon très fonctionnelle, très efficace, de maintenir leur statut social.
Et donc, quelque part, ils n'ont pas de bonnes raisons d'arrêter.
Donc, ils n'ont pas cette carence en termes d'empathie, mais ils font en sorte de-
De ne pas se sentir coupables
...pas trop l'écouter, cette empathie
Exactement. C'est vraiment cette idée-là. On n'est pas tellement sur des enfants qui seraient nés avec tout d'un coup une petite jauge d'empathie à zéro.
On est plus sur des enfants qui sont capables de désactiver leur système d'empathie, de culpabilité, etc. Quand ça les arrange.
Et en fait, ça non plus, c'est pas complètement incroyable parce qu'on est tous capables de le faire. Et donc ça, c'est tout ce qui concerne en fait le modèle du désengagement moral. Avec cette idée que
toi comme moi, comme tout le monde, on a tous des principes moraux et la plupart du temps, on essaye de les suivre, parce que, ben ça nous procure plutôt des sensations positives, alors que si on les transgresse,
automatiquement, on va plutôt ressentir de la culpabilité, de la honte.
C'est pas agréable à vivre, donc on évite. Sauf que, ben y a toute une série de petits mécanismes qui nous permettent de désactiver sélectivement quand ça nous arrange nos principes.
Donc, si tu veux, de réinterpréter la situation pour faire en sorte que nos principes ne s'appliquent pas. Je te donne un exemple tout bête.
Si en venant ici, tu as croisé un SDF et que tu lui as pas donné une pièce, ben je doute que tu vas ronger de culpabilité toute la nuit.
Mh.
Et pourtant, t'as certainement un principe moral qui doit être quelque chose du style, aider quelqu'un qui est dans le besoin ou quelque chose, on va dire, qui s'en rapproche.
C'est quelque chose qu'on est tous capables de faire. D'ailleurs, vivre à 100 % en cohérence avec nos principes moraux, ce serait pas forcément possible.
Et donc ces enfants vont simplement utiliser ces mécanismes hein. Tu sais, ça peut être déshumaniser la victime. Donc, par exemple, si un enfant donne un surnom à un autre, imaginons qu'il l'appelle le singe,
ben c'est plus Thomas, c'est plus Pierre, c'est le singe.
Et le singe, c'est beaucoup plus facile de lui faire du mal qu'à Thomas ou à Pierre qui est une personne comme moi, qui éprouve des sentiments, etc.
Et y en a toutes sortes comme ça. 'Fin, y en a en fait une série qui ont été théorisées par Albert Bandura, qui est un psychologue très connu.
Et donc ces enfants vont en tout cas utiliser ça pour se sentir tout à fait en paix avec leur conscience. Ça veut pas dire pour autant qu'ils sont incapables d'éprouver de l'empathie.
On estime que les enfants qui manqueraient réellement d'empathie, donc un peu, 'fin de façon pathologique, c'est moins de 3 % des harceleurs scolaires.
Tu fais une séparation entre deux profils.
Mh.
Et si j'ai bonne mémoire, dans l'article que t'as écrit à ce sujet, tu fais aussi la séparation entre deux types d'empathie qui sont dans un premier cas, la question de l'empathie cognitive.
Donc par exemple, dans le cas de ce que tu appelais la grosse brute pas très maline, pas forcément en capacité de réfléchir sur : « OK, qu'est-ce que ressent précisément la personne avec laquelle j'interagis maintenant ?
Et inversement, l'autre profil que tu présentais de très intelligent, socialement très populaire, etc.
Ce profil-là va plutôt mettre une chape de plomb sur son empathie affective pour, voilà, essayer de, comme tu disais, déshumaniser, ne surtout pas trop se préoccuper de-
Ouais
...de ce que peut ressentir-
Et c'est important de comprendre la nuance parce que du coup, ces enfants-là, ils ont une excellente empathie cognitive.
Ils savent parfaitement ce qu'ils font ressentir à l'autre en disant ou en faisant telle chose. Et du coup, parfois, quand on propose des programmes très larges qui vont travailler les compétences émotionnelles,
mais sans forcément, ben voilà, s'adapter finalement au type d'enfant qu'on a en face de soi.
Alors, je dirais que dans le meilleur des cas, peut-être que ça, simplement, ça ne sert à rien, mais dans le pire des cas, on est peut-être même en train de leur donner davantage d'armes pour harceler les autres.
Ouais. Et si je dis pas de bêtises, tu faisais aussi une corrélation entre l'âge et les deux profils. Donc voilà, le-
de nouveau, je reprends tes mots hein, mais entre guillemets : « La grosse brute pas très intelligente », c'est plutôt chez les très jeunes en primaire et inversement, le profil très populaire qui va,
voilà, victimiser une personne dans sa classe pour
se, voilà, monter dans la hiérarchie, se hisser au-dessus.
Ça, c'est plutôt chez les adolescents.
Avec l'âge, effectivement, on a de plus en plus de profils, on va dire stratégiques-
Mhmm
...et de moins en moins de profils, on va dire déficitaires pour ne pas appeler ça grosse brute sans empathie.
Ce sont tes mots, mais ouais.
Je réfléchirai deux fois avant de choisir mes mots. Mais donc oui, probablement. Et ça va de pair avec le développement des compétences, tout simplement, cognitives, etc., des enfants.
Alors adolescents, et je dirais même pré-adolescents, je pense que vers la fin du primaire, on peut déjà commencer à voir davantage de profils stratégiques, populaires, etc.
Et du coup, pour continuer sur la question du profil, si on s'intéresse à la question du genre, est-ce qu'on a raison de penser que c'est surtout un truc de mec, le harcèlement ?
Non, non. C'est-à-dire que, alors, des différences de genre, y en a, mais elles sont vraiment légères. Et ce sont des différences qui ne sont pas très significatives, on va dire, dans la pratique.
Donc oui, si on regarde, si on passe des questionnaires, etc., on va probablement avoir une légère surreprésentation des garçons, que ce soit dans le rôle de harceleur ou de victime.
Mais on parle vraiment de différences qui sont pas, oui, pas significatives pour la pratique, je sais pas le dire autrement.
Mais par exemple, est-ce que c'est tout aussi fréquent pour un jeune garçon d'harceler un garçon qu'une fille ? Ou est-ce que y a des règles un petit peu implicites qui font que
on se concentre sur les personnes du même genre et on essaie de ne pas embêter-
C'est pas le champ que je connais le mieux-
D'accord
...mais si je dis pas de bêtises, c'est effectivement un petit peu plus fréquent au sein du même genre et un petit peu moins intergenre.
Maintenant, il faut aussi bien comprendre que dans la façon dont on mesure le harcèlement, ça peut avoir une incidence sur les résultats.
Donc, par exemple, si dans les questions, on parle de comportements comme frapper, donner un coup de poing, un coup de pied-
Voilà, ouais
...on va avoir tout d'un coup une surreprésentation des garçons. Si on ajoute à côté de ça une autre question qui va plutôt être griffer, tirer les cheveux, pincer, et ben ça va s'équilibrer.
OK.
Et donc faut aussi bien se dire qu'il y a des formes d'agression qui sont moins admises socialement chez les filles et donc qui prennent des formes beaucoup plus discrètes, en fait, camouflées.
Quand on parlait de harcèlement, moi, j'avais plutôt en tête le harcèlement verbal, systématisé.
Social.
Voilà, c'est ça. Si on essaie de mettre les choses en proportion, les violences physiques par rapport aux violences verbales-
Elles sont moins importantes.
Ouais.
Donc, t'as tout à fait raison de penser que les formes qui prédominent, c'est effectivement le harcèlement verbal qui est quasiment omniprésent hein, les petites moqueries, les insultes, etc.
Puis le harcèlement social, donc exclure quelqu'un-
Mhmm
...répandre des rumeurs, des choses comme ça. Et puis seulement arrive la forme physique. Puis, on a du harcèlement qu'on pourrait qualifier de matériel.
Donc on s'en prend plutôt aux possessions de quelqu'un. On va-
j'avais un témoignage comme ça d'une jeune femme qui me disait : « J'ai retrouvé ma carte d'étudiant découpée en petits morceaux dans ma chaussure après un cours de gym ».
Mais c'est d'une violence folle, évidemment. Et en toute dernière position, on a le cyberharcèlement. Et ça, c'est intéressant parce que c'est peut-être finalement ce dont on parle le plus dans les médias.
Et évidemment, ça ne veut pas dire que c'est moins grave, mais ça arrive beaucoup moins souvent.
OK.
En tout cas, en primaire, ça, c'est certain.
Oui.
Et je connais un petit peu moins la façon dont ça se distribue en secondaire. Je pourrais m'attendre à trouver un peu plus de harcèlement type physique chez les garçons.
Je pourrais m'attendre à en trouver plus dans des écoles peut-être plus défavorisées. Maintenant, ce qui est quand même très important de savoir, en fait, c'est que d'une école à l'autre, y a pas tellement de différences en termes de
fréquence, taux de harcèlement scolaire.
Peut-être les formes peuvent varier, mais pas forcément le nombre.
On a beaucoup plus, peut-être, mais surtout beaucoup plus de différences d'une classe à l'autre, donc d'un groupe classe à l'autre-
OK
...et aussi forcément d'un enseignant à l'autre, et beaucoup moins d'une école à l'autre.
OK.
Donc, par exemple, c'est totalement faux de penser qu'une école dans un milieu plus bourgeois ou plus favorisé, il va y avoir moins de harcèlement.
Et comme tu dis, les formes seront peut-être différentes, mais voilà, vraiment, ça, c'est une idée reçue aussi.
D'accord, OK. Et du coup, tu parlais d'harcèlement qui peut être plus fréquent, plus important, dans une classe par rapport à une autre.
Mmm-hmm.
J'allais te poser la question : qu'est-ce qui fait, qu'est-ce qui peut jouer dans un environnement pour favoriser ou défavoriser la présence de harcèlement ?
Alors, y a beaucoup de choses qui peuvent jouer et ça, c'est important aussi de le penser comme ça, de bien se dire que le harcèlement, c'est multifactoriel.
Donc, on peut vraiment investiguer les facteurs qui y contribuent à des niveaux différents.
Au niveau de la classe, alors y a plusieurs choses. Je dirais qu'y a une question de norme qui s'établit dans la classe.
Donc, c'est-à-dire la norme, on parle des comportements qui sont considérés comme normaux, c'est-à-dire qu'on doit avoir, qui sont attendus dans la classe et qui sont considérés comme étant, voilà-
La norme sociale, ouais.
La norme sociale.
On en a parlé avec Olivier Klein dans le dernier épisode.
Ah ben voilà. Donc y a cette question de la norme. Alors
moi, je parlerais de norme perçue parce que bien sûr, c'est toujours la perception que les élèves en ont et ça peut devenir intéressant d'ailleurs de se rendre compte qu'elle est pas forcément
cohérente avec ce qu'ils pensent, finalement, si on les interroge tous un à un,
mais on y reviendra peut-être.
En tout cas, cette idée de la norme, elle est importante parce que forcément, elle est influencée par les attitudes individuelles.
Et donc, si on a une majorité d'élèves dans une classe qui vont avoir des comportements, ben de type harcelant ou dominateur, etc., ça va instaurer une norme qui va plutôt être pro-harcèlement.
À l'inverse, si on a beaucoup d'élèves qui sont plutôt des défenseurs, c'est-à-dire quand ils assistent à une scène de type harcèlement ou une injustice, eh bien, ils vont se lever, ils vont s'interposer, etc.
Eh bien ça, ça va plutôt instaurer une norme anti-harcèlement. Et donc y a des facteurs comme ça, vraiment au niveau du groupe.
Après, y a évidemment les facteurs individuels. Et on n'oublie pas, bien sûr, le rôle hyper important de l'enseignant. L'enseignant qui est quand même un modèle super important pour les élèves.
Et donc on se rend bien compte qu'entre des enseignants qui ont un message très très clair, très très explicite, quant à leur
non-tolérance du harcèlement dans la classe
et d'autres enseignants qui peut-être sont du même avis, mais qui ne l'expriment pas de façon aussi claire pour les élèves, on se rend bien compte que ça a une incidence directe sur le taux de harcèlement dans la classe.
Donc l'enseignant qui est limpide par rapport au fait qu'il ne tolère pas ce genre de comportement dans la classe, qu'il n'approuve pas, eh bien, ça aura déjà tendance à diminuer la probabilité que ça survienne.
Une idée reçue qu'on entend parfois, c'est, aux États-Unis, dans le high school, on a beaucoup plus de harcèlement, que c'est beaucoup plus violent, que voilà, c'est très présent dans les films hein, les-
Mmm.
Les jocks qui vont taper sur les nerds et les enfermer dans leur casier et tout ça.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette idée que dans les cultures qui sont beaucoup plus individualistes que les autres, on a davantage ce besoin de, voilà, justement, créer une hiérarchie, s'installer
au-dessus et victimiser les autres pour se valoriser ?
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette idée-là ?
Alors, je précise à nouveau que c'est de nouveau pas un champ dans lequel je suis vraiment-
Une intuition
...spécialisée, mais je préfère le préciser parce qu'il y a des choses que-
C'est normal
...que je dis en étant assez sûre de ce que je raconte. D'autres où voilà, c'est un petit peu plus... Mais je suis vraiment pas sûre parce que,
le harcèlement, c'est un problème qui est aussi très très présent, notamment dans les pays asiatiques qui sont connus pour être justement des sociétés plus collectivistes-
Oui
...moins tournées vers l'individualisme. Et pourtant, y a vraiment tout un champ scientifique sur cette question-là qui s'est développé dans ces pays-là spécifiquement.
Donc j'aurais pas tendance à forcément mettre ça en lien. C'est sûr qu'à un niveau très très large, le climat général d'une école va être plus ou moins favorable à l'apparition de situations de harcèlement.
Alors, j'ai bien dit qu'il y en avait partout, hein, mais
y en a plus quand même, ben voilà, légèrement plus dans des écoles qui vont avoir un climat, par exemple, très très compétitif, qui vont pousser les élèves à être compétitifs entre eux, etc.
Ça, on sait par exemple que c'est très très nocif. Donc en fait, tout ce qui a tendance à favoriser les inégalités.
Et tu me posais-
C'est justement quelque chose que j'attribue très fort au système scolaire américain. Ça a le côté très compétitif, très inégal.
Alors, potentiellement, maintenant, nous, on a un des systèmes les plus inéquitables, enfin les plus inégalitaires d'Europe, et en plus relativement inefficace donc...
Et du coup, là, est-ce qu'on observe du coup une corrélation avec l'importance du harcèlement scolaire chez nous par rapport aux autres ?
Alors, disons que c'est une piste d'explication. Mais, voilà, en fait quand on a des corrélations, il faut toujours rester très pru-
Bien sûr
...très prudent dans l'interprétation. Parce qu'une corrélation ne veut pas dire qu'il y a un lien de cause à effet. Et donc du coup,
parfois, j'hésite un petit peu à te répondre oui, parce que je me méfie de ce que ça peut véhiculer comme message.
Mais c'est une piste quoi.
C'est une piste.
C'est une piste. Une piste qui te séduit, qui t'intéresse ou ?
Ça n'expliquerait qu'une si petite part des différences qu'on constate, par exemple d'un pays à l'autre, que honnêtement,
je suis beaucoup plus intéressée par la gestion, on va dire, vraiment sur le terrain, ce qui se passe au niveau de l'école, au niveau de la classe et ce qu'on peut faire à ce niveau-là.
Parce qu'on peut agir sur les politiques très très globales au niveau de la communauté très très étendue, mais il faut pas s'attendre à avoir des résultats palpables, significatifs facilement.
Donc c'est vraiment, le harcèlement, c'est plus humain qu'acquis, c'est plus dans notre nature profonde qu'un phénomène sociétal.
Bah, y a des auteurs qui le postulent, ouais. Bah René Girard, dont je parlais tantôt, il postule l'existence d'un inconscient persécuteur chez l'être humain,
avec cette idée qu'on pourrait tous et toutes, dans un contexte particulier, devenir des bourreaux, en fait.
Oui. Est-ce que la figure du harcelé qui devient harceleur, c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve souvent ou... ?
Bah pas tellement. C'est pas la première fois qu'on me pose la question et, bah je dirais pas qu'elle me surprend, mais c'est vraiment pas quelque chose qui me paraît si fréquent.
Donc ça peut arriver certainement, mais c'est pas une tendance.
Inversement alors, le harcelé qui finit par excuser, légitimer ses comportements en se disant : « Non, c'est normal, c'est bon, y a pas de souci.
C'est quelque chose qu'il faut pas remettre en question. »
Donc la victime de harcèlement. Alors oui, ça par contre, c'est une stratégie d'adaptation. C'est-à-dire que, à un moment,
c'est tellement insoutenable, c'est tellement atroce à vivre, de se dire qu'au quotidien, on subit, on souffre, on,
on subit, voilà, des avanies de la part des élèves qui nous entourent de façon tout à fait injuste, injustifiée.
On n'a rien fait pour mériter ça. C'est horrible de se dire ça. Et donc y a
beaucoup de victimes qui, à un moment ou un autre, finissent par se dire : « J'ai dû le mériter d'une façon ou d'une autre » ou : « C'est normal, en fait, que ça m'arrive.
Voilà, c'est parce que je suis bête, c'est parce que je suis moche, peu importe », mais qui finissent par trouver une explication qui au moins donne une certaine logique à ce qu'elles vivent.
Parce que c'est presque plus supportable que d'être confronté au fait que non, c'est absurde ce qu'elles sont en train de subir pendant des semaines, des mois, des années.
Oui, donc les fameuses stratégies d'adaptation ou stratégies de coping. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres stratégies de la sorte ?
Y en a beaucoup et c'est même intéressant de se rendre compte que les victimes, elles ne restent pas passives par rapport à ce qu'elles subissent.
Parce qu'on a parfois peut-être l'image un peu cliché de la victime de harcèlement qui se laisse faire, qui subit, mais qui finalement, presque provoque un petit peu ce qui lui arrive.
Et il faut bien se rendre compte de plusieurs choses. D'abord, c'est que les harceleurs ne choisissent pas leur cible au hasard.
Ils ont tendance à choisir une cible,
une bonne victime, j'ai presque envie de dire. C'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui va être un peu isolé socialement ou qui va être un peu anxieux, qui va en tout cas avoir l'air de ne pas représenter un danger pour les harceleurs.
Donc quelqu'un où il y a finalement un faible risque de représailles. Et donc, ils choisissent probablement des personnes déjà un petit peu fragilisées ou qui vivent un moment de leur vie qui les fragilise.
Et ce qu'on sait aussi, c'est que par ailleurs, le harcèlement, ça a deux conséquences principales, c'est l'isolement social et l'anxiété.
Et donc on a une espèce de cercle vicieux qui fait qu'être victime de harcèlement rend anxieux et isolé socialement. Et donc-
Ce qui favorise encore plus notre statut de cible.
Exactement. C'est pour ça qu'on a malheureusement beaucoup de cas de changement d'école qui sont des échecs parce que même transposé dans un nouvel environnement, l'enfant a tellement intériorisé
ses caractéristiques que c'est comme s'il arrivait avec un grand panneau au-dessus de sa tête : « Je suis une bonne cible ».
Et donc le harcèlement se répète. Et ça, c'est atroce évidemment pour l'enfant qui le subit, qui finit par se dire : « Mais c'est vraiment moi qui ai un problème.
» En fait, toute différence peut être un prétexte au harcèlement. Et donc potentiellement, aucun enfant n'est à l'abri, même un enfant pour qui tout va bien dans son histoire scolaire, etc.
Et puis qui vivrait, voilà, des événements qui font que tout d'un coup, il se retrouve dans une position plus fragile, eh ben il peut être choisi comme cible de harcèlement et subir du harcèlement pour le restant de sa scolarité, ça arrive.
Donc aucun enfant n'est à l'abri, mais comme je le disais, il y a quand même certaines caractéristiques qui augmentent le risque en fait d'être harcelé.
Et je fais référence à ce que je viens de dire, c'est-à-dire l'anxiété et l'isolement social. Après, il y a vraiment plein de victimes où t'auras beau chercher, tu comprendras pas
ce qu'elles avaient de particulier pour être choisies.
Et donc parfois, c'est des choses absolument ridicules. Il y a une victime qui témoignait et qui m'expliquait que c'était la couleur de ses yeux.
Une autre qui disait qu'elle était à l'école européenne et c'était la seule qui était moitié italienne, moitié française.
Et donc c'était la Française alors que tous les autres étaient italiens. Enfin, donc ça peut être tout et n'importe quoi.
Mais donc j'ai surtout l'impression qu'il y a un conformisme qui est très important. Il faut ne pas différer de la norme.
Ça vient d'où ça ? C'est de nouveau un truc humain au plus profond de nous ou bien est-ce que...
Hmm. J'imagine qu'il y a quelque chose d'humain dans le fait de vouloir en fait que le groupe se conforme à une norme.
Il y a ces questions d'identité de groupe aussi, hein. Si on se conforme tous à une norme, ben quelque part, on appartient au même groupe et ça permet de distinguer ceux qui sont hors groupe et ceux qui sont dans le groupe.
Et l'être humain, mais à tous les niveaux, a tendance à bien aimer les cases, les catégories et ce qui lui permet de structurer sa réalité, finalement, pour la rendre plus facile à appréhender.
Donc c'est sûrement une tendance humaine. Maintenant, je pense que dans certains groupes, elle est vraiment exacerbée.
Mais du coup, ce, voilà, ce réflexe, ce besoin de conformisme, est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est plus présent chez les adolescents que chez les adultes ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que-
Oui, oui, je pense que-
Ouais
...l'adolescence, c'est quand même la période de construction identitaire par excellence. Et donc c'est un âge où ces enjeux-là vont être particulièrement importants.
Donc faire partie du groupe, c'est très très important. Et donc, s'identifier au groupe, etc., etc. Et donc oui, y a clairement une--
en fait, y a un peu une explosion des cas de harcèlement entre, je dirais, chez nous, la troisième primaire et la troisième secondaire.
Avant ça, y en a aussi, mais y en a moins. Et après ça, y en a aussi, mais y en a moins. Ça a tendance vraiment à s'estomper plus on va vers l'âge adulte.
Mais donc y a cette période entre huit, neuf ans et quatorze, quinze, seize ans qui est vraiment très très propice.
Ouais, mais donc tu disais que c'était multifactoriel. L'âge, entre huit et quatorze ans, c'est un des facteurs du coup.
Oui.
Et donc on peut peut-être revenir à ce qu'on disait, puisqu'on a un peu fait une digression, revenir sur ce qu'on disait sur les stratégies de coping.
On parlait des attributs de certaines victimes qui vont intérioriser très fort la chose.
Oui, donc effectivement, pour se sentir mieux, il y a des victimes qui finissent par s'attribuer le blâme-
Mmh
...donc qui vont finir par se juger responsables de la situation. Maintenant, y a plein d'autres choses qui sont tentées spontanément par les victimes.
Donc, y en a beaucoup qui commencent par essayer en fait de changer ce qu'on leur reproche. C'est-à-dire que si on utilise une différence ou quelque chose comme prétexte, eh bien, les victimes vont essayer de changer ça.
Donc si on leur reproche, je ne sais pas, une couleur de cheveux, ben y en a qui vont peut-être essayer de cacher les cheveux, se teindre les cheveux, toutes sortes de choses.
Mais bien évidemment, ça ne fonctionne pas puisque c'est juste un prétexte. Alors, y en a aussi qui vont essayer de se soumettre au harceleur ou à la harceleuse en espérant se faire apprécier.
Donc en se disant : « Si je fais tout ce qu'on me demande, si je donne mes collations, si je, voilà, si je fais le paillasson », pour reprendre les mots d'une victime interviewée, elles vont arrêter ou ils vont arrêter.
Et bon, évidemment, pareil, ça ne fonctionne pas puisque ça renforce au contraire la position de la victime facile qui de toute façon ne riposte pas, etc.
Alors on peut parler de riposte aussi parce qu'évidemment, y a des élèves qui à un certain moment se révoltent, se rebellent contre le traitement qu'elles subissent.
Et là, ben c'est très imprédictible. Donc c'est assez bien quitte ou double. Ça va dépendre de plein de choses. Ça va dépendre de la victime, de son, comment dire, sa capacité à avoir l'air sûr de soi, affirmé, etc.
Et à se révolter au bon moment, de la bonne façon, etc. Mais ça va dépendre aussi de qui elle a en face. Donc à quel point est-ce qu'elle a un harceleur, une harceleuse ou un groupe, pareil, qui est sûr de lui ou pas.
Et donc on a des témoignages de victimes qui se sont rebellées et du jour au lendemain, c'était fini et d'autres pour qui ça a complètement empiré les choses.
Donc-- et y a beaucoup de solutions comme ça, on va dire un petit peu quitte ou double. Et on pourrait toutes les passer en revue, mais ce qui est frappant, c'est qu'y a aucune de ces solutions qui peut être, on va dire,
raisonnablement attendue spontanément d'une victime qui garantit de mettre fin au harcèlement.
Ouais.
Donc ça veut dire qu'on peut pas laisser les victimes toutes seules en se disant qu'elles vont trouver une solution et qu'elles vont bien réussir à s'en sortir parce que tous les témoignages concordent pour dire
: « J'ai essayé ça, j'ai essayé ça, j'ai essayé ça » et en fait, y a rien qui fonctionne.
Et ça s'explique aussi notamment parce que les harceleurs ou les harceleuses ne cherchent pas avant tout nécessairement à faire souffrir leurs victimes, mais ont cet intérêt dont on parlait du gain de domination sociale.
Et donc finalement, peu importe la réaction de la victime tant que ça continue à maintenir la position du harceleur ou de la harceleuse.
Et c'est quand même terriblement compliqué de s'opposer alors qu'on est déjà victime, etc., affaibli, fragilisé, à quelqu'un qui est justement dominant, populaire, qui est peut-être très doué verbalement, qui fait rire les autres.
Enfin voilà, on peut comprendre que ce soit incroyablement compliqué de s'en sortir. Et donc des conseils d'adultes tels que : ignore-les, ils vont se lasser.
Ça, il faut arrêter de les donner parce qu'en fait, ça marche peut-être avec un petit conflit, mais ça ne fonctionne pas avec une dynamique chronique de harcèlement qui s'est installée.
Mmh. Si on parle de la question de l'empathie affective par rapport aux victimes de harcèlement, voilà, y a toujours dans les classes, voilà, des personnes qui sont auteurs de harcèlement, des personnes qui sont cibles de harcèlement.
Et puis y a un paquet de gens qui sont juste sur le côté, qui regardent, qui sont témoins et qui n'interviennent pas. L'empathie chez ces personnes-là, comment est-ce que ça fonctionne ?
Est-ce qu'elles sont aussi en train de se déresponsabiliser, en train d'éviter d'y penser ?
Alors, le désengagement moral s'applique certainement aussi aux témoins. Maintenant, il y a différents types de témoins en fait.
Parmi les témoins, il y a différents rôles qui sont pris. Donc c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir des témoins qu'on va qualifier d'assistants du harceleur qui, quelque part, voient une occasion
amusante de se joindre au harcèlement et qui vont prêter main forte au harceleur ou à la harceleuse un peu plus leader, on va dire.
Puis on va avoir une position intermédiaire. On va plutôt parler
de renforçateurs, donc des témoins plus passifs qui vont pas s'impliquer, mais qui sont là, qui regardent, qui observent, qui rigolent éventuellement et donc qui
forment une toile de fond qui soutient en fait ce qui est en train de se passer. Et puis,
à l'autre extrême, on va avoir des défenseurs. Donc on a quand même des élèves qui
vont prendre le parti de la victime, alors soit de façon très frontale en s'interposant, mais il faut beaucoup de courage pour faire ça, ou alors en étant un soutien pour la victime, en étant amie avec elle ou en allant la consoler par après, etc.
Et on a ce qu'on appelle aussi des outsiders qui seraient vraiment les témoins silencieux quoi, ceux qui s'éloignent, qui essayent surtout de ne pas être mêlés à ce qui se passe.
Et donc, par exemple, les défenseurs, on sait qu'ils vont justement avoir moins de désengagement moral, moins de petites phrases comme ça qui leur permettraient, comme tu disais, de se déresponsabiliser.
Alors que chez les autres, on va retrouver, ben, une dilution de la responsabilité, hein. Donc par exemple : oui, mais tout le monde le fait.
Ou alors, l'utilisation-
Mmh mmh
...d'euphémisme : Oh ben, c'est pour le taquiner, c'est pour rire. Ou toutes sortes de-- ou une comparaison avantageuse.
Ça, c'est très, très pernicieux. C'est de dire : Oui, mais je l'ai pas frappé quand même. J'ai juste rigolé, je l'ai, voilà, je l'ai juste insulté.
C'est pas comme si je lui avais cassé la figure. Toutes sortes de petits mécanismes qui sont utilisés pour, voilà, ne pas se confronter au fait qu'on a eu un comportement immoral qui transgresse nos principes moraux. Et
les défenseurs, je dis qu'il y en a,
mais il y en a pas beaucoup. Et en fait, ça se comprend assez facilement parce qu'il y a finalement toutes sortes de phénomènes psychosociaux qui sont à l'œuvre et qui freinent la réaction des potentiels défenseurs.
Donc, on a notamment ce qu'on appelle l'effet spectateur. L'effet spectateur, eh bien, si, en rentrant chez toi tout à l'heure, tu te fais agresser dans la rue, je te souhaite qu'il n'y ait pas trop de témoins.
Parce que plus il y a de témoins-
Mmh
...moins il y a de chances que quelqu'un intervienne par effet de vraiment dilution de cette responsabilité.
Tout le monde se dit : Ben quelqu'un d'autre que moi peut ou va réagir.
Ça, c'est de la psychologie sociale, pour le coup.
Exactement. Et chez des jeunes enfants, tu as aussi un,
un monitorage collectif de la réaction. C'est-à-dire que l'enfant de huit, neuf ans qui assiste à une scène comme ça, par exemple d'humiliation ou quoi, pour la première fois,
il sait pas forcément trop comment réagir et il va observer les autres autour de lui pour calquer sa réaction sur celle des autres.
Mais forcément, s'ils font tous ça, il y a personne qui intervient. Et en plus, tout le monde va se dire que apparemment, c'est la bonne réaction à avoir dans une telle situation.
Ce qui va, en retour, créer une nouvelle norme, etc., contre laquelle ce sera très compliqué d'aller. Puis il faut pas oublier qu'il y a aussi un instinct de survie, tout simplement.
Si le harceleur, la harceleuse est quelqu'un de dominant, etc., ben voilà, c'est stratégiquement, on n'a pas envie de s'opposer à cette personne.
On veut pas non plus perdre son propre statut. On veut pas devenir la prochaine victime. Et il y a tous les enjeux d'appartenance au groupe, etc.
Si je m'oppose à ce que le groupe a l'air de trouver bien, chouette, drôle, ben quelque part, je me mets en porte-à-faux et je m'exclus du groupe.
On parlait tout à l'heure des différentes formes de harcèlement, et tu expliquais que le cyberharcèlement, c'était sans doute la forme la moins fréquente, mais malgré tout, la forme dont on parle le plus.
Comment ça se fait ?
Alors, le cyberharcèlement, en fait, il y a cette idée que ça va agir vraiment comme une caisse de résonance et que ça va décupler le harcèlement, on va dire, traditionnel.
Donc, il faut déjà se dire que c'est assez rare d'avoir juste du cyberharcèlement, indépendamment de tout harcèlement scolaire plus traditionnel.
Souvent, c'est une énième forme-
Une continuation
...qui vient, voilà, qui vient s'ajouter, etc.
Alors évidemment, je parle ici du harcèlement scolaire, hein, je parle pas du harcèlement de célébrités sur Internet ou des choses comme ça, mais vraiment dans le cadre du harcèlement scolaire, le cyberharcèlement,
ben généralement, c'est fait par des élèves du groupe classe ou de l'école.
Et donc même si la victime ne sait pas toujours qui est derrière les attaques, en général, les interlocuteurs se connaissent.
Et alors, effectivement, ça va décupler, on va dire, les attaques parce que le cyberharcèlement, il a des caractéristiques spécifiques.
Il peut arriver à n'importe quel moment, donc c'est plus limité aux heures scolaires. Tout d'un coup, ça peut être le soir, la nuit, le matin, quand on est chez soi.
Il y a pas de limite non plus, effectivement, spatialement, donc c'est plus limité aux alentours ou à la zone de l'école.
Ça se poursuit en dehors. Et cet anonymat, donc potentiellement ne pas savoir qui se cache derrière les attaques, ça aggrave terriblement évidemment la détresse qui est ressentie par les victimes.
Et du côté des harceleurs, ça peut faciliter le désengagement moral parce qu'on n'a pas de visuel, par exemple, sur ce qu'on est en train de susciter chez la victime.
On envoie un message assassin, ben le message, il sera reçu peut-être une heure, deux heures plus tard. Donc il y a un décalage temporel, il y a un décalage parce qu'on n'a pas la réaction de la victime.
Et donc ça, ça peut renforcer ce qu'on appelle aussi un espèce d'effet cockpit. Donc le harceleur est dans sa bulle, et voilà, a réellement peut-être une moins bonne conscience de ce qu'il suscite.
Donc, je reviens sur la question que je posais, c'est-à-dire si c'est la forme la moins fréquente, comment se fait-il qu'on en parle autant ?
Est-ce que c'est le fait que ce soit récent, nouveau ? Est-ce que c'est le fait que-
Oui, il y a tout ça
...il y a un certain rapport à la technologie, une certaine technophobie de : « Oh, tout ça est tellement étrange, tellement mystérieux, tellement insaisissable. »
Alors, il y a certainement de tout ça. Après, 'fin, comme je le disais, il y a le côté aggravant.
Et donc du coup, les cas de harcèlement où il y a aussi du cyberharcèlement, ça va avoir tendance à devenir beaucoup beaucoup plus grave pour la victime.
Et les cas où il y a des tentatives de suicide ou des suicides, ben régulièrement, il y a eu notamment cyberharcèlement.
Donc il y a un lien quand même, voilà, il y a un lien à ce niveau-là. Maintenant tout à fait d'accord avec toi que l'aspect technologique, on va dire, de la chose,
donne un petit côté obscur, insaisissable pour les adultes, un monde qui leur échappe, qui échappe à leur contrôle, etc.
Et ça devient évidemment très facile de le diaboliser aussi. Y a notamment des hoax, hein, des intox qui ont circulé, il y a pas si longtemps que ça sur des challenges qui pousseraient les,
les élèves au suicide ou des choses comme ça.
Ça enflamme la toile et les médias à une vitesse qui est assez impressionnante. Donc il y a un effet aussi sensationnel, on va dire.
C'est ça.
Mais il ne faut pas minimiser le facteur gravité que le cyberharcèlement confère à la situation.
En fait, avant de te contacter et avant de m'intéresser à la question du harcèlement scolaire en faisant mes recherches, j'ai évidemment cherché à voir ce qu'on en disait dans les médias.
Et je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un peu un traitement-- ben déjà, c'est un marronnier, ça revient tous les ans à peu près à la même période, le harcèlement scolaire, quelle horreur, tout ça.
Et alors c'est toujours un peu le même format de on va interroger
une personne qui est victime ou bien si la personne victime s'est suicidée, on va interroger ses proches et puis on va avoir des témoignages du style : « Ah non, on savait pas, on n'avait aucune idée que c'était aussi grave » et tout ça.
Et à ce moment-là, on revient au plateau et on va entendre soit un politicien, soit un psychanalyste qui va, voilà, donner des explications très sérieuses, condamner le harcèlement.
Et à ce moment-là, on va shifter sur OK, quelles sont les solutions possibles ? Et on va parler des affiches qui sont collées dans les écoles, des numéros d'urgence, de Child Focus, de vos trucs.
Et donc grosso modo, on place largement la responsabilité de la solution sur la personne qui est victime, qui est la cible du harcèlement.
Et étrangement, enfin ça-- en tout cas, ça m'a surpris en regardant ces émissions, on passe beaucoup de temps à expliquer que la victime doit téléphoner, doit contacter, doit en parler à un adulte.
Très peu de temps à parler des auteurs de harcèlement comme si c'était finalement, c'est inévitable quoi. Qu'est-ce que t'en penses de cette approche-là ?
Alors, je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi que c'est un peu un paradoxe incroyable de faire peser la responsabilité de la solution sur les victimes.
Et je pense que y a moyen de faire des choses et y a moyen de faire des choses à différents niveaux.
Mais je crois que c'est super important pour les écoles, pour les directions d'école ou même les politiques de toujours avoir bien conscience du niveau auquel elles sont en train de travailler.
C'est-à-dire que par exemple, si on décide de mettre en place, on va dire, un programme de prévention très général qui a pour but, on va dire, d'améliorer le climat global d'une école,
alors OK, c'est bien, mais il faut se rendre compte que ce n'est que de la prévention très générale et qui du coup, va avoir relativement peu d'incidence sur les situations de harcèlement concrètes.
Et donc il est impératif d'avoir dans chaque école une vraie procédure de prise en charge des situations. Parce que finalement, oui, c'est vrai, le harcèlement, on va jamais complètement l'éradiquer.
Il est probable que ça continuera d'apparaître dans les groupes classes, quelle que soit la forme que prendra l'école dans le futur.
Mais ce qui est hyper important, c'est d'être capable en fait de l'enrayer rapidement. Quand une situation commence à dégénérer, eh bien,
être en mesure d'intervenir et d'empêcher justement que ça se cristallise et qu'on se retrouve un an plus tard avec une victime, un harceleur qui sont tellement dans leur rôle qu'il y a plus vraiment moyen de les faire changer de position.
Et donc, l'idée du coup, c'est vraiment l'intervention. Très très concrètement, qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les situations de harcèlement qui sont avérées ?
Et l'idée clé, c'est que malheureusement, il y a pas de recette magique et il y a certainement pas une solution unique.
Donc il y a pas une formule qui serait à appliquer dans toutes les situations. Chaque cas de harcèlement est vraiment unique et différent, et on peut pas donner la même réponse à tous les cas. Et donc
l'objectif, je pense, pour des écoles, des professionnels, etc., c'est de,
de se doter d'un éventail de réponses possibles,
de multiplier les outils ou les approches pour avoir un peu de choix, pour essayer de choisir la,
la meilleure approche en fonction de la situation et surtout d'avoir d'autres approches en réserve si celle qu'on essaye en premier
ne fonctionne pas.
Et donc, il y a par exemple tout ce qu'on appelle les approches non confrontantes.
C'est-à-dire que, on va pas être dans la convocation du harceleur ou des harceleurs en disant : « C'est pas bien ce que vous avez fait », etc.
On va plutôt essayer de désamorcer les choses,
on va dire, en travaillant un petit peu dans l'ombre, en fait, pour éviter de stigmatiser la victime, et pour essayer que tout le monde ressorte de la situation, entre guillemets, la tête haute.
Alors on parle par exemple de la méthode PIKAS, la méthode No Blame. Bon, ça, ce sont des noms, mais le principe, c'est que, bien souvent, on va passer en fait par le groupe de témoins.
Donc, je disais tantôt, c'est super important, les témoins. Dans la plupart des situations, c'est pas un problème entre une victime et un harceleur ou une harceleuse, c'est un problème de groupe.
Et donc il y a toujours quasiment des témoins présents. Et par leur réaction, ces témoins, ils peuvent avoir une influence incroyable sur le comportement du harceleur.
Ils peuvent soit encourager, soit au contraire décourager le harceleur de continuer.
Mais tu parlais tout à l'heure justement de l'effet spectateur-
Mmm-hmm
...donc beaucoup de témoins, très peu envie d'intervenir. Et maintenant, tu dis : on aimerait qu'ils interviennent.
Oui, mais des témoins qu'on sensibilise au problème et qu'on forme par exemple à réagir. C'est-à-dire, ça peut être tout bête hein, ça peut être réfléchir en classe : tiens, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire le jour où on voit ça ?
Parce que simplement avoir une idée de ce qu'on peut faire, ça augmente les chances de le faire. Il y a aussi beaucoup d'enfants qui assistent à ce genre de scènes et qui ne savent tout simplement pas quoi faire
ou qui simplement se disent : OK, j'ai peut-être une idée,
mais franchement, j'ai aucune garantie que si je tente le coup, ça fonctionne.
Et donc ils vont pas prendre le risque. Mais par contre, si on travaille ça avec justement tous les témoins potentiels, etc.,
sans forcément dire : il y a un problème de harcèlement dans la classe, mais simplement en mettant le, voilà, en décortiquant le phénomène, en disant : ben tiens, voilà, ce genre de choses, ça peut arriver.
Quand on assiste à ça, comment on peut réagir quand on est témoin, etc., etc. Mais là, on serait à un niveau, je dirais, de prévention ciblée.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est déjà dans du plus ciblé, mais on n'est pas encore dans réellement juste de l'intervention. Donc, je disais
qu'on pouvait, par exemple, solliciter l'aide de quelques enfants dans la classe, c'est-à-dire ben les rassembler et puis dire : tiens, on s'inquiète pour une personne dans la classe.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce qu'il ou elle vous semble bien intégré·e ? On a l'impression qu'il va pas bien pour le moment, etc.
Et en fait, on sollicite l'empathie de ces élèves qu'on a bien choisis, évidemment hein, on les a pas choisis au hasard, et on les amène à proposer une solution d'eux-mêmes.
Et ça peut être tout simplement : ah, mais on va lui proposer de rester avec nous, on va lui proposer de jouer avec nous, etc.
Et donc, de façon relativement légère, enfin light, on va amener un soutien social à une victime de harcèlement. Et l'idée, c'est de combiner comme ça quelques petites interventions.
Donc c'est-à-dire que, ben une victime qui commencerait vraiment à,
à souffrir du harcèlement, à développer ben des symptômes, les conséquences, etc., de l'anxiété, on peut aussi évidemment lui offrir un soutien plus individuel, par exemple de type psychologique, etc.
Mais ça doit être en complément d'autres choses. Sinon, comme tu disais tantôt, ça fait de nouveau reposer la responsabilité sur la victime.
Et donc cette solution-là de responsabiliser les témoins-
Mmm-hmm
...de leur demander de passer à l'action dans une certaine mesure, est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu as eu l'occasion de tester, de mesurer sur le terrain, de voir les effets que ça peut avoir ? Est-ce que c'est-
Alors c'est-
C'est récent comme technique ou c'est... ?
Tout dépend de ce que tu appelles récent.
Ça a une dizaine d'années, beaucoup moins ?
En fait, c'est quelque chose qui est utilisé dans le programme finlandais KiVa, donc qui a été développé déjà il y a plusieurs décennies-
Mmh
...et qui a été testé, qui a été transposé
dans d'autres systèmes et qui a de nouveau montré certains résultats. Hein, je reste prudente parce que de nouveau, il faut pas s'attendre
à une efficacité phénoménale, mais qui continue, on va dire, de faire ses preuves de façon régulière, et ce, dans plusieurs contextes culturels très différents.
Donc notamment ben en Australie,
en Grèce, enfin voilà, toutes sortes de contextes différents. Et c'est vraiment au centre de ce programme-là, c'est renforcer les possibilités d'action des témoins et
avoir une équipe dans l'école qui est prête à intervenir de façon concrète, comme je disais, par exemple, en faisant venir trois, quatre élèves d'une classe et en essayant de solliciter leur aide, leur aide, etc.
Donc combiner une prévention comme ça, relativement ciblée et une capacité d'intervention de la part de l'école.
Donc c'est pour ça que je parle de ça, puisque c'est une piste, on va dire, qui a relativement fait ses preuves.
Mmh.
Maintenant, y a toutes sortes d'approches différentes, toutes sortes de programmes. Il faut savoir qu'on manque d'évaluation scientifique.
Oui.
Donc il existe énormément de choses. Des initiatives, y en a plein, en fait hein. Beaucoup d'ASBL ou de différents organismes qui se disent : on va faire quelque chose contre le harcèlement.
Et l'initiative est super, mais la plupart du temps, c'est pas évalué scientifiquement. Or, on sait qu'on peut pas juste se baser sur la satisfaction des adultes qui mettent en place le programme ou qui,
ou des enseignants pour dire que quelque chose est efficace.
Il faut réellement le mesurer au niveau des élèves, de ce qu'ils vivent, parce que inévitablement, on est des êtres humains, on a plein de biais.
On parlait de biais tantôt. Moi, si je mets en place un programme, je vais avoir envie, très envie qu'il fonctionne.
Et donc, si je me base juste sur ma perception subjective de ce que j'observe, voilà, ça, c'est, ben c'est pas ce qu'on appelle une démarche scientifique rigoureuse.
Donc évaluer, c'est nécessaire. C'est vraiment tous des garde-fous qui permettent de pas perdre l'objectivité de ce qu'on mesure.
Et on sait que c'est vraiment difficile d'avoir des effets sur le harcèlement. On sait que les effets, en général, ils sont plutôt faibles.
On sait qu'ils ont tendance à pas durer dans le temps non plus et que c'est pas parce que quelque chose fonctionne dans un contexte que ça va forcément fonctionner systématiquement dans d'autres contextes.
Donc, on peut tenter quelque chose, une sorte d'étude pilote dans une école, pardon, avec une équipe. C'est pas pour ça que l'école d'à côté, ça va donner pareil si on réplique le programme.
Donc voilà, y a vraiment toutes sortes de nuances à avoir en tête, bien se dire : les programmes anti-harcèlement, c'est pas non plus la recette miracle qui résout tout.
Oui, donc un vrai souci par rapport à ou méthodologie pour mesurer l'efficacité de ces différents programmes. Et donc tu disais, les stratégies pour responsabiliser les témoins ont montré un certain niveau d'efficacité.
Est-ce que t'as d'autres exemples de programmes qui ont montré un certain niveau d'efficacité ?
Eh bien, parmi les, oui, les composants de programmes qui, en tout cas moi, me paraissent très intéressants-
Mh
...y a notamment la question du désengagement moral dont j'ai parlé et des normes du groupe classe dont j'ai parlé aussi.
Et c'est en fait les deux choses que, dans mes travaux de recherche, j'essaye de tester expérimentalement de façon isolée, justement, pour ne pas se retrouver avec uniquement des gros programmes remplis de trucs.
Et à la fin, on sait pas finalement ce qui fonctionne et ce qui fonctionne pas. Donc j'essaye de tester en isolation certaines composantes spécifiques.
Maintenant, il est encore un peu tôt pour parler de résultats-
Oui
...mais j'espère pouvoir en dire plus prochainement. Après, le développement des compétences socio-émotionnelles, ça reste quelque chose qui est souvent plébiscité dans les programmes.
Faire prendre conscience aux élèves que ce qu'ils pensent être la norme n'est pas forcément vrai. Et rien que leur faire prendre conscience de ce décalage-là,
c'est quelque chose qui est utilisé dans des études pilotes prometteuses.
C'est ça. Et donc on en est à ce stade-là, on en est au stade des études pilotes prometteuses. Et tu-- en début de podcast, on évoquait le fait que y avait maintenant une vraie demande de la part de,
des établissements scolaires pour des éventuelles solutions, des stratégies.
Et en fait, la réponse qu'on leur propose à ce moment-là, c'est : on veut bien faire des études, on veut bien tester des choses.
Non, on est un petit peu plus loin que ça quand même-
Oui
...parce que KiVa est sur le point d'être mis en œuvre en Belgique, enfin en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, en phase test, parce qu'on va faire les choses prudemment, forcément.
Mais il faut savoir que c'est déjà le cas en Flandre. Et ici, à la rentrée, en fait, septembre 2020, ça va être mis en œuvre dans effectivement une dizaine d'écoles pilotes par les,
l'équipe de l'Université de Paix, donc qui est une ASBL qui est spécialisée dans la question justement des gestions de conflits, gestion de la violence scolaire, etc. Donc ça veut dire
des personnes qui sont déjà chez nous, qui connaissent extrêmement bien le contexte de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles et qui sont allées se former à KiVa, en Finlande, en octobre
dernier et qui collaborent, à côté de ça, avec ben notamment, du coup, l'UCLouvain,
pour mener l'évaluation scientifique des phases de test...
OK.
...histoire de ne pas se retrouver dans la situation où on diffuse un programme à un maximum d'écoles possible avant de savoir s'il est efficace.
Mh.
Parce que finalement, si au bout d'un an, deux ans d'évaluation, on se rend compte qu'en fait
ça ne montre pas les résultats qui étaient espérés, ben en attendant, c'est d'autant plus de ressources humaines, matérielles, temporelles qu'on a dépensées en pure perte.
Et donc à ce stade, tu restes prudente.
Très.
Très prudente. Optimiste malgré tout ou pas ?
Oui, optimiste, oui. Parce que comme je disais aussi au début de l'interview, c'est finalement assez récent, la mobilisation sur la question du harcèlement scolaire ici en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Et donc quand je vois ce que ça a donné dans des pays qui sont sur ce chantier depuis 40 ans, par exemple, j'ai bon espoir qu'à un moment donné, chez nous, toutes les mesures de prévention finissent par porter leurs fruits.
Donc optimiste, certainement, mais prudente.
OK. Et ça va être intéressant aussi de voir le contexte très particulier de la rentrée de septembre 2020, et le poids que ça peut avoir sur ces études-là puisque...
Est-ce qu'on sait, est-ce que tout le monde fait sa rentrée en septembre ? Ça en est où, ça ?
Écoute, je n'arrive plus à suivre au niveau des mesures de coronavirus. Je-
La science de l'éducation.
Alors oui, mais je télétravaille depuis trois mois et demi-
Oui, c'est ça.
...et donc, je t'avoue que-
Ouais.
...à ce stade-ci, moi, j'attends le moment où on me dira que je peux réintégrer mon bureau, retourner sur le terrain et-
Ouais, ouais. Mais donc, voilà, donc on te sent très prudente, mais optimiste malgré tout. Voilà, on peut parler d'un nouveau terrain d'étude sur les stratégies contre le harcèlement, en tout cas ici en Belgique francophone.
Je t'ai posé la question sur les études qui te paraissaient encourageantes, pertinentes, intéressantes. On a parlé un peu avant de lancer l'interview de stratégies qui étaient moins pertinentes-
Mh mh.
...qui avaient été, et tu m'expliquais que tu avais écrit un--
tu étais en train de publier un article scientifique sur la question, sur les stratégies qui ont été répandues et qui ont été, pardon, dont les écoles étaient très demandeuses,
mais qui, finalement, n'avaient pas une grande valeur scientifique.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de ça ?
Oui, ça, je dirais que c'est un peu un problème qu'il y a à cause de la multiplication de toutes les initiatives, des innovations pour lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire, mais qui,
voilà, ne sont pas forcément évaluées
avant d'être diffusées.
Et ben y a notamment eu, par exemple, à un moment, ça a été très très fort la tendance dans les écoles d'aménager leur cour de récréation, notamment en peignant des zones de couleurs par type d'activité.
Donc, par exemple, la zone verte, c'est la zone calme, la zone jaune, on peut courir, mais sans ballon, etc. Et-
C'est plutôt les écoles primaires alors ?
Plutôt les écoles primaires, oui. Mais à un moment, ça a été aussi dans certaines écoles secondaires. Mais moi, effectivement, j'ai surtout suivi ce qui s'est passé dans les écoles primaires.
Et en fait, bien entendu qu'aménager un espace de cour de récréation, c'est toujours bénéfique, c'est toujours intéressant.
Y a rien de mal à ça. Ça peut même, voilà, effectivement permettre aux élèves de trouver finalement chacun le type d'activité qu'il aime, etc.
Donc, pourquoi pas ? Ça, certainement. Mais le problème, c'est qu'il y a eu peut-être un raccourci,
dans l'esprit de pas mal de directions qui se sont dit : « Si je peins ces zones de couleur dans ma cour de récréation,
ça va régler la question du harcèlement scolaire.
» Et là, pour moi, scientifiquement, y a un problème parce que déjà, au niveau, on va dire théorique, y a aucune raison de penser que de mieux gérer l'espace dans une cour de récréation va résoudre des dynamiques de harcèlement scolaire.
On en a discuté ensemble, on voit bien que c'est très très spécifique, que ça s'apparente pas à juste un conflit ou une dispute.
C'est très différent des autres formes de violence.
Et très multifactoriel donc-
Et très multifactoriel.
Les histoires de couleurs dans la cour de récré, ça me paraît un peu simpliste.
Voilà. En tout cas, on n'observe pas que les écoles qui auraient des cours de récré mieux aménagées, avec des jeux, etc., auraient moins de harcèlement.
C'est pas du tout quelque chose qui se vérifie, on va dire dans les données.
Comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé au stade où des écoles ont pu, entre guillemets-
Alors, je dirais que-
Entre gros guillemets, 'fin, acheter cette solution alors que pas de valeur scientifique, pas de vérification des effets, pas de preuves...
Alors, y a deux choses. Je pense que, alors d'une part, il y a
eu, entre 2015 et 2017, une évaluation qui a été menée pour justement essayer d'objectiver un petit peu les effets du programme que j'évoque.
Alors forcément, pour pouvoir les évaluer, il a fallu que des écoles acceptent de le mettre en œuvre, et de tenter l'expérience.
Donc ça, c'est tout à fait normal. On peut toujours tenter, hein, une, comment dire, on peut toujours évaluer quelque chose quand on souhaite en connaître les effets.
Mais je pense qu'il y a aussi eu un effet du contexte un petit peu d'urgence dans lequel on se retrouvait.
C'est-à-dire que tu parlais de l'effet marronnier en parlant du harcèlement scolaire. Ben, à l'époque, y a eu, comme y a d'ailleurs quasiment chaque année, un drame qui a été particulièrement médiatisé.
Et suite à ça, ben les politiques ont un peu fait leur cheval de bataille autour de cette question-là et ont dit : « Il faut absolument, absolument que les écoles soient équipées, qu'il y ait un programme dans toutes les écoles le plus vite possible.
» Et donc, ben là, parfois, voilà, y a comme un-
OK.
...une incompatibilité finalement entre la démarche scientifique qui nécessite du temps, de la prudence, de l'expérimentation, etc.,
et l'urgence, ben, du terrain ou la demande politique qui veut que les choses soient faites vite et que surtout, on ait quelque chose de très visible de part les écoles, les parents.
Or, les cours de récréation, c'était-
La peinture, ouais.
...très catchy, très, très visuel. Ça permettait de dire : « Ben voilà, regardez, nous, on fait quelque chose contre le harcèlement. »
D'après ce que t'expliques, c'est une large partie, un besoin politique ou un besoin électoral.
Oui, et je trouve que, 'fin, la démarche du politique a eu, je dois leur reconnaître que ce qui était très intéressant, c'est qu'ils ont pensé à mener l'évaluation dès le début du processus.
Parce que le problème qu'on aura-- et c'était une première en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, hein. On a très très souvent des choses qui sont mises en œuvre et après coup, on se dit : « Ah, ça a l'air de marcher.
Ce serait bien d'évaluer pour savoir si ça fonctionne. » Mais c'est presque trop tard par après parce qu'on n'a pas un temps de mesure antérieur et un temps de mesure postérieur qui permettrait vraiment de voir l'évolution des choses.
Quand la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles fait une étude sur l'efficacité de ses propres décisions, est-ce que ce genre de choses se fait publier ?
Est-ce que c'est disponible ? Est-ce qu'il y a une omerta ou euh...
Alors, je pourrais pas dire comment ça se passe de façon générale-
Mmh.
...mais actuellement, en tout cas, les deux rapports qui ont été publiés dans le cadre de cette évaluation-ci, ils n'ont pas été publiés.
D'accord.
Ils n'ont pas été rendus publics, non.
OK.
Ils existent. Sur demande, ils peuvent être consultés.
Ouais.
Mais non, y a pas eu ce-
Et du coup, quel impact ça a sur ton travail à toi, ton article ?
À l'époque, je dois dire, si je veux être vraiment honnête, que ça m'avait assez bien découragée.
OK.
Faut se dire que c'était le début aussi. 'Fin, je commençais à travailler dans la recherche, etc. Et donc je pense que j'ai vraiment un peu vécu ça comme une perte de sens.
Je me suis dit : « Mais je fais tout ce travail-
Des illusions.
...je mets en évidence, voilà, que quelque chose, par exemple, ne fonctionne pas ou en tout cas que l'étude ne permet pas de montrer des résultats.
» Et j'ai l'impression que ça ne sert à rien et qu'en fait, au niveau politique, on va pas prendre en compte-
Tu te sentais un peu muselée, euh...
Ben en tout cas, je me suis sentie impuissante. Et donc ça a été un peu décourageant. Après, je pense que comme je disais, il faut aussi se dire qu'y a peut-être un changement qui est en train de s'effectuer.
C'est-à-dire que si la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles commence à prendre le pli d'évaluer systématiquement ce qu'elle fait, de se dire : « C'est une nécessité.
Si on met quelque chose en œuvre, si on essaye un nouveau truc, on doit l'évaluer », ce serait déjà franchement un grand pas en avant.
Donc si ces rapports ont permis au moins d'alerter en disant : « Attention, ce n'est pas parce que quelque chose est beau, semble extrêmement prometteur, etc., que forcément ça fonctionne », finalement, c'est déjà pas mal.
Et donc le programme qui est sur le point d'être introduit, testé doucement, prudemment en Belgique francophone. Et on peut, d'après toi, être optimiste, on peut avoir espoir que ça porte ses fruits sans certitude, mais on peut l'espérer.
Et peut-être voir les choses s'améliorer en ce qui concerne le harcèlement scolaire en Belgique francophone.
Oui, d'autant que c'est un programme qui est aussi mis en œuvre aux Pays-Bas, et qui fait ses preuves.
Or, le système éducatif des Pays-Bas est déjà beaucoup plus proche, on va dire, du nôtre que le système finlandais.
Donc j'ai bon espoir. Maintenant, il ne suffit pas de proposer ou de parachuter dans une école un programme efficace pour que l'école parvienne à-
Bien sûr.
...à s'en saisir et à le mettre en œuvre de façon également efficace. On sait que juste cette question de la mise en œuvre, elle explique probablement la moitié des résultats qu'on peut observer.
Et donc y a aussi cet enjeu-là. Et cette mise en œuvre, elle doit aussi être évaluée. Sinon-
OK.
...en fin de processus, on est incapable de savoir si on n'a pas de résultats parce que le programme est inefficace ou parce qu'il n'a pas été mis en œuvre correctement.
On introduit doucement, prudemment ce nouveau programme en Belgique francophone, mais le déploiement doit se faire très lentement, doit être contrôlé.
On doit vérifier que c'est implémenté de façon optimale partout. On doit observer la façon dont c'est implémenté-
C'est ça. Donc l'idée, c'est qu'il ne suffit pas d'évaluer juste la question des effets. Il faut aussi aller sur place, descendre sur le terrain et se rendre compte de ce qui est fait réellement, concrètement.
Donc autrement dit, y a une lumière au bout du tunnel, mais c'est pas pour demain. Ça va prendre encore un peu de temps avant que ces programmes anti-harcèlement soient déployés à grande échelle, contrôlés, vérifiés, optimisés.
Ça prend encore un peu de temps.
Ça prend du temps.
Ouais.
Et malheureusement, voilà, c'est pas toujours la même temporalité-
Mmh.
...entre la recherche, les écoles, le politique.
Ouais.
Mais oui, pour que ça porte ses fruits, c'est sûr que ça va prendre quelques années. Maintenant, y a quand même beaucoup de choses qui sont en train de se mettre en mouvement.
Et donc j'ai bon espoir qu'on arrive à des premiers résultats, en tout cas, d'ici
deux, trois années maximum, qui vont permettre à ce moment-là, s'ils sont positifs, d'étendre et là, de mettre évidemment beaucoup plus de moyens puisqu'on aura de quoi justifier d'injecter des financements, etc.
pour permettre une diffusion à grande échelle.
Chloé, merci beaucoup.
Je t'en prie, Guillaume.
Au revoir. Voilà, j'espère que vous avez apprécié d'entendre Chloé. Elle n'est pas sur Twitter, mais vous pouvez retrouver son travail sur son profil ResearchGate.
J'ai mis le lien dans la description. Dans les semaines qui viennent, j'espère faire un épisode sur le racisme systémique, en raison de l'actualité aux USA et, peut-être aussi faire un épisode sur la politique belge.
Si vous avez la moindre suggestion, n'hésitez pas à me faire signe sur les réseaux sociaux. Vous pouvez suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur Facebook et Twitter.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Et bien sûr, si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné, pensez à le faire, ça rend plus beau.
On se retrouve bientôt. À très vite !